the challenge is to do it all the time
um the challenge is to sit there
basically because there's so many times
when you just want to flee it's it's not
the life that I would have thought it's
more difficult in some ways the actual
act of writing is both more difficult
and more rewarding the replay you have
searched States of something like
ecstasy in your writing when it goes
well when it goes specially well and
that's not something you can imagine
when you're first starting out it
certainly wasn't what happened to me
those first few times I wrote poems but
then the going on with it is quite hard
there was a period when i renounced it
when I was oh how old was there better
right after I published my first book my
life was a mess I was separating from my
then wife and I just decided let this
life of a poet is killing me I have to
do something else but I couldn't well I
thought of writing screenplays I had a
friend who was a director in Hollywood
and I said I want to be a director and I
said that's impossible but try writing
some screenplays so I SAT that and i
started my found it very boring so i
just sat at my desk for a few months
really doing nothing but keeping the
same hours i did when i was writing
poetry and then i started writing again
and i started writing in a new way and
it was very exciting was actually after
my second book
it's always difficult question for a
power what's next you never know whether
you're going to write another poem it's
one of the I mean you have faith that
you will but you never know for sure you
never know for sure if the light will
come if the force will take you if the
music will happen so sometimes I think
maybe I should try something else now
maybe I should write the novel I never
wrote or something although i really
have no gift for that or no patience for
but i hope i'll just write some poems i
like
you